you've heard it in Catholic prayers and
you've heard it in good songs now it's a
movie my soul to take in 3d which really
ceases to impress me at this point all
right so before I knew what my soul to
take even was or who directed it I was
watching the trailer and before his name
came up
I said out loud this looks like Wes
Craven [ __ ] and then three seconds
later pal Wes Craven presents came right
on the screen true story now if I really
wanted to I could make this the shortest
review I could ever do it could be as
easy as acting horrible scripts worse
than the acting the story actually the
multiple personality thing that had some
potential a little bit but it was still
crap and boom there you go done now the
story is this Ripper killer kills a
bunch of people and then seven babies
are born on the night that he supposedly
dies maybe but you don't really know and
then bla bla bla sixteen years later
each of the kids has a bit of the Ripper
soul in him and one of them might just
be the Ripper killer born anew and then
of course each of the seven start
getting picked off one by one and well
as a wise man once said when you first
saw the trailer to this movie this looks
like Wes Craven [ __ ]
true story now the characters for one
are just absolutely horrible and Hollow
and they all have cell phones from 10
years ago so I got to assume that this
movie takes place in the year 2000 for
absolutely no reason whatsoever not a
big thing just an annoyance really I
mean you honestly literally don't give a
[ __ ] about any of them of the seven that
are in mortal danger I could probably
remember three and that's because one
was Asian I mean it's like they're high
school students who are like the
caricatures of high school students like
there's this one girl who's like The
Godfather of the Twihards I mean she
runs the doings and dealings that the
high school social circles from a confab
thrown in the girls bathroom I mean
honestly give me a break I'd always
imagined what girls do in the bathroom
together but it was always normal [ __ ]
like involving pillow fights and
chocolate syrup and
right and the dialog forget about it
like there's a scene in the beginning of
the movie where a guy gets an
epinephrine shot then he wakes up and
shoots a cop in the chest twice and the
one thing that the cops cop buddy could
say is whoa epinephrine is the [ __ ] like
seriously dude your friend might be dead
that's all you gotta say who writes this
[ __ ] oh that's right the guy who's known
as the master of horror will be taking
that cops badge and will be taking that
crown of the master of horror from you
Wes Craven I'm sorry and as for the
killer they explain away his strength
I'm saying that he's possessed by some
sort of demon that's why he's super
strong but there are scenes where he
looks enormous like he looks like Tyler
main in the suit and there is no buddy
in this movie that's as tall as the
killer looks in this movie especially
the one who turns out to be the killer
I mean that's like having Billy Loomis's
mom kill Randy oh wait [ __ ] Wes Craven
did that too awesome now because of the
nature of this movie I will say that
this movie might be okay not only if
you're drunk but if you're shit-faced
hammered and I was a party however
because of the simple fact that this
movie's target audience isn't even old
enough to drink yet I gotta say [ __ ]
am I the only one who finds it strange
or ironic that the target audience for
these rated-r slasher flicks can't even
buy their own tickets yet that's weird
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]